everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 320 of the askgaryvee
show and this is a very exciting episode
because the person that will be dialling
the questions and getting to the
questions today is India our very own
India who's on her last day after seven
years at vaynermedia moving to Portland
so everybody in Portland if you see her
stop her take a selfie posted on social
tag-me but fun fact for a lot of you
that don't know India was a superstar
you know you know how sometimes they
like you know like Ari Gold actually
became the star of Entourage but that
wasn't the purpose there was absolutely
a time in 2015 in 2016 where India was
the my main co-host of the show when it
was a completely call-in show or or take
questions from the internet show and you
know the reason I had to get her off the
show was it became clear to me that she
had become bigger than me and I wasn't
really willing to deal with that you
know and I've just been an amazing part
of our team and I love her very much
it's fun to have you here when was the
last what was the first up do you know
the first episode you were on 20 it's
amazing so it's fun to have you here for
all the new cats go back and watch some
of those shows like episode 32 200 or
150 and you'll see a bunch of India and
I interactions it's a lot of fun so
thanks for being on all so exciting we
have the marketing firepower Behind
NASCAR an organization that we've at the
Vayner X level have worked with a little
bit but more importantly just my love of
sports and marketing I'm always looking
for guests that make that cross so it's
super excited to have you guys here why
don't you guys to introduce yourselves
to the vaynernation
and before you do that putting your
phone numbers on YouTube and Facebook if
you want to call in and ask questions
I'm gonna go pretty question heavy here
especially if you're into sports
marketing into NASCAR itself or
marketing itself as you start listening
to the framework ladies first
thank you I'm Jill Gregory I'm the chief
marketing officer at NASCAR I've been at
NASCAR Steve Phelps here hired me 10
plus years ago big fan of the sport but
was not growing up and
the potential that we've got at NASCAR
to keep growing is huge so thanks for
having us of course you and I'm Steve
Phelps I'm the president of NASCAR and
I've been with NASCAR almost 14 years I
think 14 years next week
I did grow up a NASCAR fan worked at the
NFL for almost 14 years and then
transitioned over a NASCAR and it's a
phenomenal place to work in a great
sport let's lean into this because I
think for everybody's watching to make a
connection point with the vaynernation
and you guys I'm obsessed my whole last
decade of my career is to be to build a
machine this marketing communications
machine to buy nostalgic businesses and
brands you know and what's been really
fun being 43 is and loving sports is
there's been incredible patterns in
NASCAR in culture as a net sport over
the last 50 years for that matter I want
to go into that orange story where did
you grow up and why were you a NASCAR
fan sure so I grew up in Vermont I see
on India's book there we've got the
Vermont sticker
thank you for there's like you know
they're not a lot of us there so hold on
I apologize India why do you have a
Vermont sticker god dammit I forgot that
okay I grew up in Burlington Vermont yep
so so my dad was a big NASCAR fan there
was a track about 15 miles from our
house which is no longer there called
Catamount Speedway oh kademan and so I
went there the first time when I was
five years old my brother and my dad and
my father was nice enough to tell me you
are absolutely have to root for the
Vermont drivers no one from New York no
one from Quebec after we flew no
Massholes
no a lot there so was who's your
favorite driver yeah my driver of my
favorite driver at 5:00 was the driver
of the number five white number five
because his Speed Racer
unfortunately he was from Quebec and so
my dad forbid me for for Rudy for that
driver his lot his name was cabana
see it was super interesting about this
me and make you just smiled like a lot
of people even this just a couple days
ago always asked me why do I put up
number five when I take photos with
people like I actually when I chose the
Jets is my favorite team at five
my favorite player player was Pat Leahy
the kicker who wore number five and to
this day everything like five is a very
it's funny that you were that age when
you and like that's why that's funny
yeah so but I'm the fifth president of
NASCAR so maybe it's so but yeah so I
you know NASCAR like most sports very
generational generational transfer so I
started with going to the racetrack and
the sights and the smells and the sounds
of what it's like to go to a NASCAR
track it was a short track as I said
doesn't exist anymore there but that was
my first love of the sport and it grew
and so I have denoted a little bit when
I got into college I really got back
into it and then gotten the kind of the
sports world and I remember a time when
Paul Tagliabue who was the Commissioner
was there Paul was he brought me up and
he said hey I hear you're our resident
NASCAR expert and I gave him a tutorial
on NASCAR so it was pretty cool that's
read and how about for you you come into
the role in the were you CMO right away
eleven ten or eleven years ago first and
marketing grew up within it ya know we
created a group when I first started a
NASCAR designed to I mean this was like
I said quite a few years ago but it was
designed to help the drivers with their
brands so prior to us creating that
group and it was probably a very
primitive version of what we all do
today but it's trying to get these
drivers to understand that it's not just
about what they did on the racetrack
because I think their whole mindset was
I get in the car I go fast and I go home
I sign a couple autographs and I call it
a day and obviously today what they do
in the car is almost secondary I mean
you got to win on the track and you've
got to be a competitor but the things
that they do on social engaging with
fans is sponsor events way more
important than it used to be so we
started that that's when when I joined
ask are just a three-person team and now
it's grown into kind of our entire
marketing organization
is built on those driver brands for
everybody was listening knowing the the
sport what what is a good three minute
rant and like the current state of
NASCAR for people that are considering
it or watching it or you know give me a
little three minutes on the current
state of the sport
you want me to rant go grant okay so I
would say you know we have been at the
period of time over the last third four
years where I would say five or six our
most popular drivers retired and so when
that happens we had we knew we had to
refresh the kind of the drivers yes
money for everybody's listening knowing
what we talked a lot about it happened
to the NBA after the Jordan you know
bird magic thing my favorite come for
this is wrestling since McMahon controls
the narrative but it still comes down to
the actors and the athletes and so after
Hogan and macho in Andhra giant there's
a gap and then you know the rock and
Stone Cold come along and it reads and
so you you guys say for us yeah so we
had junior yeah Stuart
Tony Stewart Jeff Gordon Carl Edwards
Danica Patrick yeah those are those are
big names in our sport and many had been
around for two decades and so for us
like any other brand any other sport you
refresh the brand yes so we've got a
phenomenal group of young drivers this
crop is the both the largest and you
know the the skills the personalities
the authenticity of who they are and the
great news is they can win and you can
be have a great personality be very
charismatic our fans want the drivers to
win you know this is a debate and and
pontificating that I have with you guys
and just so everybody's listening my
incredible observation of the next 20 30
years is that the direct social scale
does for the first time ever create a
debate of winning on the field being a
direct attribute because I do think that
we're gonna be able to see 360 no
different than people are vloggers and
influencers and they're not winning
anything you know Ken America or the
world become fascinated by a human just
based on their
backstory their life story by the way
you're talking to a sports fan who
actually drops his teams when they win I
stopped being a Yankee fan and Rangers
fan after the Rangers won in 94 new
Yankees won in 96 so I'm in it for the
climb if I got behind a racer I probably
young young who was you know I probably
love the two or three or four years on
the underdog I want I want the process
of trying to win more so the winner but
nonetheless to your point winning has
always been the variable for max
popularity but but you guys have a
pedigree sport one thing I know that's
interesting about you guys the Elliot
kid now Dale jr. I remember watching
that very carefully like as a casual fan
just knowing when you are a second
generation of an icon
you know you definitely have a pretty
big fan base before you've won which I
always feel super compassionate and
empathetic towards that kid because the
pressures yeah impossible when you look
at Dale jr. early in his career and I
think part of why he has transformed
into such a great media personality is
that you know early on you have to think
that pressure was a lot for him to
handle and I think as he continued to
get older and then even now when he's in
the booth broadcasting races he's much
more comfortable with kind of his role
in his legacy and you can see that and
kind of how he interacts yeah it's a
tough piece I mean Petty's kid raced
right yeah you know like and like not as
successfully of a career like it's it's
tough yeah well it's time you know
Richard Petty the king he's you know
it's no one's gonna that's the level I'd
love to I need to make that happen
33 43 see that seat to me like that's
interesting the fact that I know that
like just speaks to like how much of an
impact he had on cold you're like yeah I
mean listen anytime your dad is known in
anything as the [ __ ] King your punch
line
like that's gonna be a problem bad news
Xander marketing is gonna be tough for
you
I think Dustin all right I think the
interesting thing too so you talk about
these you know young stars that we have
and authentic and charismatic you take
the the guy who currently runs for
Richard Petty
it's Bubba Wallace yes the American kid
phenomenal personality yes and you know
not afraid to show his emotion now not
afraid I'm he's funny he's it's just
he's just a cool guy you've got you know
a cell you have Danny suarez who's from
that for Mexico's in this series so
we've got these young you know
up-and-coming winners on the racetrack
that can wheel a race car that that's
resonating with our fan base so right
now I believe and this is maybe I'm not
an expert to say this but just my own
eye test
I think the racing that we have right
now on our race tracks the best we've
ever had a lot of innovation you know
one of the things that I admire from
afar the sports doing is you know look
by losing those you know big names by
different TV dynamics over the last 15
years you know 10 years there you know
we are not at the apex of NASCAR as we
sit here today in the way that we were
you know what would you consider you've
been there 14 years you're a fan what is
like the the last real white hot kind of
like era would you say I would say you
know probably Oh 709 yeah like you know
like was that was that one next hell was
that was next okay man in 2004 yeah with
that season yep so you know what's
really interesting is you know this is
something I yell about with baseball and
I think they're finally starting and I
have empathy baseball is suck you know
when you start getting into 200 years
and [ __ ] but you guys are really
innovating like you guys are you guys
are doing things that I you know I kind
of slightly am curious what the
old-school 30 40 50 year fan is thinking
like when you start changing sports
people you know heck I'm a die-hard
football fan and i weirdly don't want an
18-game schedule for one weird reason it
throws off me understanding how to
calibrate stats you know like like so a
change is hard now but you guys have
absolutely shown the willingness and
I've been ounce more changes to come
like innovate you know and from a
business standpoint I'm always innovator
died that has not been the historic
point of view of sports
at all I agree and I feel like you guys
I'm trying to I'll let you talk but
outside of rogue leagues not rogue
leagues other leagues most of
basketballs innovation came from the ABA
you know Moton most of the innovation
for the NFL came from the USFL or the
XFL like it usually comes when you see a
pop of that you guys are doing it
yourself we are no I don't think it's a
for us we think what's important to do
exactly that because fans even existing
fans and then new fans feds are trying
to get to to watch our sport we need to
make sure that they are entertained and
you we've been criticized about hey
you're chasing the entertainment you're
chasing what the answer is yes it needs
to be compelling and so we have created
things like stage racing so three
different segments of our races and then
there are points you can get as a driver
that help you get to our playoffs right
so playoffs new concept for us no we
introduced segments new concept that we
introduced different you know the rate
the racecar itself and what we're doing
today and where we're going with the
racecar in the future what's been the
reaction to that you know it's
interesting let me he's always public on
I'm curious I promise I'll let Jill talk
please I think I get excited I think for
us Jill did it this is appropriate
I had three cousins a drug meet him the
local dirt track so they're all just mad
at me still today that I have this job I
think I think for us a lot of the things
that we have introduced there's a
typically it's a 50/50 right so you have
half your fans that say hey I like ya
and half don't yeah and so we've been
able to do because the things you know
we do a lot of research and a lot of
analytics and insights in terms of what
we believe is going to work and
sometimes fans don't know what it's
going to work they don't you know
they're kind of stuck and hey this is
what I like yeah I mean so it's changes
to change his heart if I listen to my
customer I would have made a faster
horse it's something you know and you
guys know I'm always like listen to the
customer and then I always counter it
with that that's just the truth so and
so for us it's kind of in
happens right so we've been able to in a
lot of different things that we've done
so playoffs you know more than eight out
of ten of our fans say hey that's a
great idea started at fifty stage racing
started at 50 now we're well up over
eighty percent so we're we're always
trying to listen to the fan and kind of
iterate around it but it's it's so we
have is caught up to change what he's
doing the most interesting thing the
last year or two from marketing
standpoint you know just it can be
completely anything it could be an
attack that you did on Instagram it
could be a brand coming to you that it's
like just hot take some of the
interesting stuff on the intersection of
marketing in this car most a lot of what
we work with you guys on I mean the
explosion of content like I would we
need up we would never say that it was
good that we had the retirement of all
of those big stars that that clearly was
not the case but I think you should
write and given where where the world is
going these young drivers are eager to
prove themselves they're out there
they're social natives they are ready to
take on the challenge so we would have
had a harder time I think adaptations
with the yeah with those veteran drivers
that are like you know what I know what
I can I need to do so I'm good this has
been working at me for 20 years
screw you Jeff you know like you you
tweet I get out of my face I'm busy
yeah who's uh who's this is the name of
the person okay
beans and rice with Izzy hello beans
you're on the askgaryvee show with the
nascar crew
holy [ __ ] yeah they have my heart drop
yep what I'm glad you're on beans I
really am and I love that uses Z at the
end of the the beans part I think that's
very clever so what's your question
haha Wow I can't I can't even tell you
how much that means to me um I'll get
right to it
thank you guys for having me but my
question is uh with NASCAR I'm really
not really into that for it personally
but I'm wondering how the needs have
changed over time how maybe like some of
the cha
is that y'all faced in the 90s or the
2000s
what were they and also what are the
needs and challenges facing elf today
and how they differ beans real quick
just so cuz I'm always I love this stuff
what sports what sports if any are you
into basketball but really I'm a
musician so the I'm not a huge sports
head and I'm like really really far from
being a NASCAR fan but with much respect
there I have a lot of respect for you
that's great and and why basketball in a
world where you're so hard music did you
play it is it like your friends like job
just curious of the mapping of fandom
yeah I think I think just culture
Jordans which I not realizing you hate
[Laughter]
playing like pickup games at school and
playing in middle school on the team
I appreciate beans so what are the
challenges let's just break it down and
I'll DJ beans this question cuz I'm
curious for myself actually when it was
at its best moments highest rings ours
YT moment and cuz I don't think you're
right you're down right now for sorry
especially when I look at it
historically but in comparison to your
YT moment what were the challenges then
and what are the current challenges in
your perspective yeah I think that
challenge is that I think there are a
lot of opportunities in the 90s and
there was a kind of an explosion of
NASCAR a lot of it had to do with kind
of taking what was considered to be a
southern sport yeah and expanding across
the country so yeah beans just to give
you context like back in the day this
was like oh that's that country thing
like you know it was like there was a
very you know specific geographic know
by the way just to put into context no
different than the cross was the
Northeast thing like there's a lot of
these things surfing only surfing in
Oklahoma you know and so like you know
there's a lot of that but it was really
huge sport it was unbelievably regional
so yeah I agree so I think there there
are different challenges there were
media challenges because NASCAR races
were on third
you know 12 13 different networks
networks consolidated and solid on the
meteorites in you know one and but just
the kind of the expansion it was his
first national boost worldwide of sports
like like that's where like I click as a
real young kid and probably happening
even before I was like that's probably
why no petty like it feels like
worldwide of sports or was that well I
take 2500 Daytona 500 79 Daytona 500 the
big fight big punches being thrown
brothers involved it was like the
seminal moment and then we do mean
Evening News from everywhere yeah yeah
and so then Americans like wait then
here's what I'm sure it was the first it
was the first live broadcast as well so
a lot of things came together was the
fight staged no they put the helmet on
little brain links out they do they
still [ __ ] jump out a brother how
many of each other like Tony Stewart was
great for that really really good he was
he was angry a lot yeah that's how I
rolled
so that was shot and what about now so I
think now you know we've certainly got a
number of challenges that we are
overcoming I think that the retirement
thing was certainly but I think just you
know people's the TV switch right cuz
Fox was your big play in that in that YT
moment and I don't recall but that's
always Fox
yeah so we had Fox and then we had NBC
TNT TNT and then we had we switched back
to ESPN yep and then we are now Fox and
NBC guy so we have great media partners
but I think it's you know people's time
we need to make sure that we're relevant
and yeah so that's why the changes to
the racing itself because we want it to
be as exciting as it can be so we want
to race it and the tracks that people
want to go to to see the racing that we
want to see we want you know close
competitive side-by-side racing guys
mixing it up on the track and in some
cases off the track so but it's people's
time is valuable
yeah compelling story to break through
there's so much when I look at how much
time is being spent watching my videos
on YouTube the first thing I was go to
him like my god 20 years ago that was
going into TV shows magazines like
that's one little healing man just me
yeah so he's like if I agreed so you
take it you take a look at television
ratings right so our TV ratings this
year all sports down nine percent yes
just fewer people watching television
Yeah right
the aunt cord cutters never cords cords
shavers but it's just not watching TV or
a generation my little guy six-year-old
would rather watch a baseball game on
his iPad with updated moments he has it
on but he only watches on the iPad cuz
he likes to see all the data around they
at bat he the game is literally on he's
not watching it because he's watching it
in real time on the iPad and that's
exactly in your adapting to changing
needs and we do the same thing right so
for us you know our ratings this year
were plus three so are we back and
killing it we're coming
we're on to something and TV in general
I also wanted to jump in and ask does
that compel you to try to convert maybe
viewers who are obsessed with another
sport like hardcore basketball fans are
hardcore soccer fans do you ever take
the time to try to convert or you just
really focus from the people who already
like mascot the beans part of your
question was just ok the rice part of
your question so I would I'll take this
until can jump in I think you know we
want to convert people who who are where
there's fertile ground right so if
someone is just into you know basketball
listen we have a ton of crossover with
other sports so believe it or not
they're folks that watch golf that also
love NASCAR that makes the biggest the
biggest crossover for us actually is the
NFL we have there's also that that
crossover for us is is huge what about
college football you don't Scott
football for me that feels super
intuitive right the epicenter of college
football sits in a demo that in the
south east no question so you know for
us we need to make sure that we're that
we're nurturing the folks that we have
because we want to keep that hardcore
fan and but then we need to find this
younger more younger more diverse fan
where's that and we're working working
on a sport that isn't thinking about
youth and diversity is looking to not
win 2030 and storylines matter right
they want it people want storylines and
you want to see somebody that looks like
you that's exactly the best thing to
happen to baseball with Jackie Robinson
I mean so let's move on
ya know it's really cool it's really
interesting to me because you know also
one thing that I think people are
starting understand because of eSports
and really let's call it is the growth
of a go ahead the growth of a proper
football you know soccer in America you
know the you know it's really
interesting to understand that hey beans
hey thank you you're welcome
you know watching these Sports soccer
grow like you know reminds us you know I
guess not a meeting you know or actually
in a prior meeting you know the heavy
week heavyweight champion of the world
was the most famous athlete horse racer
horses were more famous than football
players
hello Steven yeah it's Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on the askgaryvee show
gary vee sale you today um well say
hello to the nascar krill yeah
are you Steven well I think you made a
great segue to my question is talking
about eSports they're guys II so we got
a driver right now William Byers drivers
are number 24 car who made his start
racing and erasing and you got a big
event this week on NBC where you're
televised i racing he racing for the
very first time what does the sport the
future of that look like for NASCAR yeah
gradually yeah it's just it's a great
question I think that the fact that
William Byron sat on the pole the
Daytona 500 and did no racing until he
did I racing misses our simulated and
eSports product is a story that hasn't
been told you could start doing than
saying so you could be and that's the
pinnacle of our life I'm not sure there
is another sport that will have that
happen you can't go play Madden and then
go play for the Jets well maybe you
could play which is actually remarkable
and like actually look I think that
soccer matters in America cuz of FIFA I
was there when the first FIFA Nintendo
Sega Genesis game came out and I bought
it because I bought all video games back
then and none of my friends wanted to
play because nobody gave a [ __ ] about
soccer in 1994 and then slowly but
surely FIFA got bigger and bigger bigger
I mean I mean but again back to that
point you're not playing for Liverpool
after being awesome the fact that you
guys have that might actually be the
singular and lock well I think the
hardest thing for us is you can't go
play NASCAR in the backyard right so
back to the guy who said basketball
right I was thinking that exactly so
this is a way that you can participate
and understand how our sport works and
get to be good at it without having to
go to a racetrack we want everybody
because the race the chill I apologize
you guys think that that was gonna
happen when you first rolled out the
program or did that was that even too
big of a leap for you guys that
somebody's gonna sit at home get great
at this and then actually be a [ __ ]
player well I don't think we could have
never scripted that ourselves we get
accused of scripting a lot of things
that that was gonna happen no no he's
driving Jeff Gordon's car this kid
William Byron who was doing nothing
fifth at age 15 picked up art yeah great
he's a great kid and he's driving one of
the most iconic cars at the highest
level and so I think that the more
people that understand and get it get it
exposed to NASCAR through I with you
like I'm not sure I made the connection
point for the questions Stephen thank
you for asking I actually think there's
the complete unlock I it's crazy like
that will capture the imagination of an
enormous amount of girls and boys that
are like the only place you can go from
video game to actual profession isn't
NASCAR
actually that's true well I think the
other component to that too and you
alluded to it you can't go in the
backyard and do it I mean you but you
can do it online and you can do iRacing
and it is incredible simulated racing
well clearly that's the point that I
didn't make the connection on which is
you got that the product is so good
that's right that the mapping of being
great at it Maps enough to real life
that's nuts
well I think the nice thing about it too
is car racing is expensive and so you
can figure out early and often whether
you're good at or not so you're not
spending you know hockey's biggest issue
it's expensive to be in youth hockey
which eliminates a lot of great athletes
from ever getting into the pipe yeah and
the fact that at that NBC is gonna
broadcast it I mean that's gonna be huge
exposure for it and that's the Stevens
question is that you know the fact that
our media partners are taking this
component of NASCAR seriously is is
gonna be even bigger and expose more
people to it Steve and I appreciate the
question yeah no problem thank you very
much thanks for watching the show all
right let's get one more in that was a
great question yeah that's really good
you know I really got to tell you I
think there's something real real there
like I think that's something that you
have that is so much of an advantage
compared to any other sport I agree well
I think the other thing too is the
people did do I
Racing they're absolutely nuts about it
and that's that's the cool thing that's
the passion this is Josh Josh it's Gary
Vaynerchuk here on the askgaryvee show
okay things are good please say hello to
Stephen Jill hello Steve and Jill I'm
doing my best to hear you it's all quiet
I'm there with it thank you guys
no worries what's your question so the
question as I put it forth in the
comments there was I think it's
interesting looking at sponsorship as
something that's the way I have no huge
NASCAR fan so I'm not posing here but I
live you know everybody's familiar with
the concept of the patches being on them
and all that stuff
and I imagine there's a lot that has
gone into that and as far as drivers and
their promoters their mark their
managers marketing and using that as a
cross pollination thing culturally and
business-wise of course trying to drive
business and I think it's interesting
looking at that compared to influencer
culture and all the things that you
talked about as far as damming and
whether you're looking over for the
business angle of a business users to
promote their agenda or vice versa I
think that's fascinating so I'm curious
if you guess there could speak a little
bit to that kind of model and yes you
could speak to how that relates to what
influencers should be doing today well I
think for our drivers I mean they the
sponsors can be in the field of play the
sponsors are their personal partners so
it's not slapping a logo on a uniform or
getting a personal services agreement
they are in the fabric of what makes
these drivers tick so I think for us
it's you know we've got to pay attention
to that I think where we also kind of
struggle a little bit integrate some of
the sponsors are actually integrated
into the product but some aren't right
no they are but they are yes so the M&MS
car you know the most integrated could
be is he or she's eating the M&Ms during
the race yeah which may happen you know
Dick Trickle used to have
in his car right we know the director
this story but there but your brand is
on the car your brand is on the feet
your very few brands or any field and
even the NBA which is gone progressive
obviously soccer and Europe is probably
the only comp right the NBA has been
that's I mean that little logo in the
top left is really tipping your toe
right in comparison to your point which
even soccer which is at it's scale right
a car is much bigger than Jersey well I
think the other thing is our fans
they're passionate and they're trained
they expect sponsorship they want to
wear the jacket with the huge Eminem's
logo on it or the and so that makes our
sport I even more value so just because
I buy things at garage sales and sell
them knowing that M&M culture and
collecting is real I assume some people
become fan of the driver because of
Eminem's oh absolutely
especially well think about your
five-year-old example kids like Kyle
Busch because he drives the Eminem's car
and then they grow up to be tiny boy
bands the candy man you know Budweiser
and Dale like that you know that
mattered it was a really good brand fit
yeah that makes sense I mean look I
think that I think that um we've I think
that what people don't realize is this
is a huge advantage for NASCAR in a
couple different ways in my opinion but
where it really gets interesting is I
think almost every human is gonna do a
sponsor deal in 2040 I think by the year
2040 most humans in our society are
going to be in a place where they'll do
some sort of commercial transaction
through them because I think technology
will advance enough that you know my
dream for my brand's is to actually get
the alpha mom who has 212 followers on
Instagram but she influences seven
people on her block it we're at school
and basically I want to give her a free
bottle of wine that you know that's what
she is Warren to my business but I wish
I could do that now like it just there's
a lot of dollars that go into the people
finding that there's not infrastructure
but that's where that's I mean I think
it's crazy I think I think it's not out
of the question
that the dynamics we see a mask are
actually translate to people driving in
real life that if you told me by 2060
everybody's car was sponsored out I'd be
like I understand you know they're not
gonna get the kind of numbers that all
the racers get but I think it's really
cool and I think I think there's a lot
of uh there's a lot of clever bridges
that can be built absolutely
I appreciate the question thank you so
much thank you Gary you I need to take
one moment and just say thank you I
discovered you about two months ago and
deal with a lot I was watching your
you're interviewing mr. Lowe the other
day and I deal with a lot of things that
he has talked about and I want to tell
you that they're really listening to you
and your podcast Daly has done more for
me than any pill or any other way that
I've had to medicate as far as getting
my ass going and being enthusiastic
about life and I'm wearing your shoes
and I got your hoodie thank you you're
amazing thank you you can't omit you
know you can keep the shoes and hoodies
you can return that sentence I meant the
world to me thank you brother thank you
bye
you have something to say about the
Kevin Love podcast I've been dying since
our business meeting and now yes I mean
I think that it's more lighthearted I'm
more lighthearted pieces the caps of
what it was I I took offense to your
comment that all Warriors fans are been
like these but bandwagon really really
bad mood types that are you real worse I
have a real warriors fan Run TMC yep
listen Jamie mentioned Chris yes listen
there are real warrior fans yeah the not
all are but the stunning amount of
percentage of bandwagon warrior fans is
extraordinary well I mean out the kids
who get inspired at six seven like you
know what am I gonna do there I'm
actually talking about the the courtside
seats yeah forget about the richest
people in Silicon Valley and they could
buy it and they're completely full of
[ __ ] and they like the Lakers ten years
earlier or whatever you know as fans I
don't need I don't even know most of
them well enough to know as humans I'm
talking about the masses that are
sitting in you know 12 rows back who are
also quite well-off that I actually
fully know the hundreds of them that I
met during my two thousand six seven
eight nine years
oh those years in Silicon Valley every
week every other week every month and
being a sports fan and wanting to talk
about things besides nerd tech in 2007
maybe you could find a San Francisco
Giants fan because they were playing
well but literally when I would say
things like you know what do you you
know what do you what do you think of
Monte Ellis
they were like who's that and I was like
what about the Warriors and like who are
they
yeah I was like you know the Golden
State Warriors are here and they're like
they are just so you know gary was so
passionate about his lack of knowledge
of any true Warriors fans that he wanted
the Cavs to win that series she was
excited even though he's actually not
that wasn't it I'm sorry miss the nuance
it's that I hate Michael Jordan so much
that I've been rooting for LeBron since
he was a high school play I didn't miss
that yeah oh and if tomorrow there's
hype around a new 15 year old that
person will immediately become somebody
I adore and hope wins seven
championships so they can be the number
one the neck Jordan could be not the
next but like to me like every like
Anthony date like I actually it is
literally nicks and then LeBron to win
as many rings as possible because I just
hate Michael Jordan that much I
genuinely do final final points that we
didn't get to for both of you Joe I
thought I would say give NASCAR a try
what you're gonna see is huge
competition back stories passion drama
and you've got a group of drivers that's
really compelling to watch and you know
what action relic you just said I was
just saw this I see a big cross so I had
a lot of friends through the years that
I grew up like that like wrestling
really get into NASCAR because what you
just said stories you know there's some
real slick every sport has on RAM but
there's so much tradition in NASCAR that
II a it's a second or third generation
kid or B it's the first mexican-american
to do it it's the first Asian about like
you know the first Phoebe like there's
so much tradition
either you're part of the establishment
or you're breaking ground into the
establishment and it always makes for
compelling stories yes and all with the
wide swath of drivers we have there
relatable so I think there's you can
find a driver that used to look at and
say seems cool he likes the kind of
music I like he had the same upbringing
I had including about one of the only
major sports if not the only major
sports that is a place where we will see
females play that the same high same
level absolutely
she's moving to Portland you have to be
woke just gonna walk your way to
Portland
yeah I think the cool thing about it too
is our guys by and large our guys aren't
prima donnas they're just they're
authentic to who they are
oh they definitely have a hockey DNA
right yeah so everybody always talks
about masks around whatever theories
have a theory about that good my theory
about that is these guys so your your 17
year old 17 years old do you want to ask
this girl to go to the prom go ahead
your national karting champion yes she
is going to go with the backup tight end
to the party thousand versus you a
hundred so yeah you don't every time
every time and so you don't have you
have to stay grounded and that's what
these guys are they are grounded and
they are hockey and some baseball's
biggest problem is sometimes they stay
too grounded yeah you know I think I
think you know they think of
storytelling and putting out content as
showboating instead of just sharing
information you know I wish you know
yeah there's been a lot of guys that are
gonna break through and I'm like this is
the showboating right that's what you
need to do how do I change a tire yeah
you you even you'll even see that when
they talk about you know success that
they have and they'll say they thank
everyone else but it's not like hey I
kicked ass today
the guys back at the shop or the crew
hey the crew more fascinating parts of
the sport I mean like the pit that crew
matters yeah that gets into like my
favorite like I've always used the
offensive line quarterback analogy with
the pit and driver yeah drivers gonna
get all the headlines right but like you
know the offensive line
really matters yeah pit crew really
matters really really real you know and
they're tremendous athletes and it's
phenomenal it's like the booze mmm are
better athletes like net athletes than
the drivers like net net like if you
just think about like you know my
question right no like what I did a ton
of debating I could be wrong what can
I'm like some yeah they're like they've
got like they're jacking up a 3,500
pound car they're running around
changing tires and the Pens like jumping
over sliding through it's like every
second matters right so it doesn't I
appreciate you guys being in the show
thanks for a thank you appreciate it
thank you good luck India India any
parting shots you have been you've been
crushing content the king
thanks listening we have a new nickname
on this episode we wish in the other
great
goodbye and we talk NASCAR that was
awesome